et salut à tous les amis c'est françois
pour la chaîne explique moins encore
aujourd'hui on fait un tuto sur de la
photo pour passer super simplement en
utilisant juste trois applications de ça
à ça un trop beau
[Musique]
alors on a tendance à penser que pour
faire de belles photos il faut forcément
un gros appareil très très cher et bah
c'est pas forcément mais tout simplement
parce que le meilleur appareil photo
c'est celui qu'on a avec soin et celui
qu'on a le généralement le plus souvent
c'est celui-là alors il faut savoir que
les capteurs photos des smartphones ont
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup progressé ces
dernières années et qu'on peut arriver à
sortir des photos vraiment assez classe
je suis pas en train de dire qu'un
smartphone c'est mieux qu'un reflex mais
vous allez voir qu'avec quelques petites
bidouilles on peut facilement arriver à
avoir un rendu vraiment super sympa
donc c'est parti pour ce tuto on va
utiliser trois applications gratuites et
une photo prise à l'iphone est bien
évidemment ça marche aussi pour android
alors la première application qu'on va
aller chercher ces lightroom pour
travailler un petit peu sur les
contrastes et les couleurs donc je vais
aller dans la pellicule récupérer cette
photo ici prises avec l'iphone qui est
joli mais un petit peu terne donc
première chose on va aller dans lumière
et on va augmenter un petit peu le
contraste on aura à sombrer un petit peu
l'image donc on va récupérer un petit
peu d angle qu'on a perdu
ici voilà ensuite j'ai ce verre ici et
ce blu qui me plaisent voudrait les
booster un petit peu on va aller dans
couleurs et cliquez sur mix ici on va
pouvoir gérer chaque couleur
indépendamment et en cliquant sur ce
petit bouton avec le luron et les
flèches ici on va pouvoir sélectionner
directement la couleur alors je vais
booster la saturation de ce ver ici pop
là pour le faire un petit peu plus
ressortir et idem pour le bleu n'a pas
trop quand même là et alors ce bleu ici
ne me convient pas je voudrais qu'il
soit un peu plus six ans donc je vais
expliquer sur teinte et voilà si je vais
par ici voyez le violet à limite vers on
va partir on ne peut plus sûr du
destitution voilà comme ça
et ici c'est plutôt pas mal alors je
vais juste booster un petit peu les
tonalités orange en saturation se voit
pas trop mais ça va faire une petit
effet sympa et je clique sur terminer
juste pour finir ici d'un effet moi un
truc que j'aime bien c'est la clarté ça
donne un petit aspect un peu plus nette
ça fait ressortir les détails voilà pour
lightroom c'est terminé on va
l'enregistrer dans la pellicule à leur
deuxième application qu'on va utiliser
maintenant c'est une application qui
s'appelle lentz distortion qui va
permettre d'ajouter des petits effet ici
lumineux alors ici on a le soleil qui
est quelque part par là donc on va faire
un petit effet de style alors c'est pas
obligatoire moi j'aime bien ça donne un
petit côté un petit côté sympa voyons va
prendre 20 de trucs
voilà comme ça alors je peux le déplacer
un bien sûr et je peux le réduire
permettre aussi gros quand même et hop
là le soleil le rayon de soleil qui sort
directement depuis derrière la petite
montagne petite colline voilà voilà
c'est pas folichon c'est peut-être un
petit peu grossier mais bon ça passe et
je vais deuxième phase ont enregistré
mon image alors leinster sean c'est une
application gratuite mais qui propose en
payant d'avoir plus de distorsions
possible d'avoir plus d'effets lumineux
et ses dernières applications qu'on va
utiliser et bien c'est tout simplement
instagram up moi j'aime bien regarder en
entier alors instagram s'il faut savoir
que bien souvent on va avoir tendance à
utiliser ces filtres là qui sont un
petit peu dégueulasse quand même mais ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'on a quand
même cette possibilité ici de modifier
et les outils d'instagram en manuels
comme ça sont plutôt plutôt bien fichu
et vous allez voir comment peut on peut
améliorer ici on va dans structure
monter un petit peu pas trop parce que
sinon on va voir des petites aberration
mais ça va augmenter le niveau de détail
il des mici on va aller sur estompé pour
donner ce petit ce petit voile ici ce
petit effet vintage qui assure beaucoup
beaucoup de photos instagram
on va pouvoir rajouter aussi un petit
peu encore de netteté pour avoir encore
plus de détails pas trop non plus pareil
sinon il y aura des aberrations
ici je me dis que j'ai mis le voile un
peu trop fort va retourner ici estompée
voilà on va réduire un petit peu quand
même cela c'était un petit peu too much
voilà et pour finir pour ceux qui aiment
moi j'aime bien un petit peu de
vignettes pour assombrir les coins et
voilà c'est terminé
boum il n'y a plus qu'a publié voilà
vous avez vu c'est vraiment pas très
compliqué
du bon après c'est assez subjectif moi
je trouve la photo joli mais voilà en
deux minutes on peut arriver à sortir un
truc vraiment classe et puis souvent les
gens se disent mais non c'est pas pris
avec un smartphone ce pas possible si si
si c'est un smartphone et ça marche
plutôt bien juste il faut garder à
l'esprit que il faudra quand même un
environnement assez lumineux pour
prendre de bonnes photos avec un
smartphone par en soirée ce sera
forcément un petit peu dégueulasse voilà
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu que
vous allez faire de super belles photos
avec n'hésitez pas à mettre des liens
vers vos photos dans les commentaires
pensez à mettre un petit pouce bleus ça
fait toujours plaisir et si vous êtes
nouveau ici n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
pour ne louper aucune nouvelle vidéo et
moi je vous dis à très bientôt pour une
nouvelle vidéo
tu m'as
oh
hélas